Kevin Hale welcome to the podcast hi
Craig you are running startup school
this year me and adora okay are hosting
and the main instructors for start
school so many people know about startup
school we've talked about on the podcast
before what's different in 2019 2019 is
a reaction to all the stuff that we
learned from 2018 and so I'm gonna talk
about some stats so last year we had
over 15,000 people register and
participate in start-up school and we
had about 5,000 graduate from that
graduating class we had about 391 of
them end up getting interviewed for the
last batch and then we accepted over 60
companies it represented 30 percent of
the batch the start of school now
represents the single largest source of
companies that have are accepted into a
YC batch which is super exciting
mm-hmm because the founders in start
school are so different than what I
think a lot of people think a YC company
is so more numbers there are you um 83
percent of people who started doing
start at school they were pre-launch so
no traction whatsoever
52% were working full-time so the other
40% was only part-time sixty-three
percent were single founders which was
very surprising to us
who not so many teams and then 59
percent were international and so for us
I wanted to make a new version of start
of school that was going to be a better
fit for all those different groups of
people because I felt like the last one
probably wasn't a perfect fit mm-hm and
so we shifted the content so it's more
focused on helping you understand ideas
evaluating them the way an investor
would sort of think about them so that
way if you are spending time on a
start-up part-time or you're by yourself
or you're trying to figure out like how
do what to build an MVP for you have the
tools necessary and you have the things
that we help our companies do evaluate
for example a pivot
or evaluate like which of the ideas is
worth spending time on the other thing
we did was for all these single founders
we realized there's like holy crap it's
like over six thousand people who were
like all trying to do a start-up yeah
and we constantly tell people like
finding a co-founder is the best thing
you can do first startup and so we're
like why don't we just help them do that
mm-hmm and there's a super important for
us because like we're finding
increasingly teams are being created and
other people are asking for equity to
help them find co-founders other people
meaning other investors or investors
incubators programs etc and for us we
actually feel like the only people you
should be giving equity equity to for
co-founder is two other co-founders so
we're gonna make that free we're
building a directory we're allowing you
to state that you are looking for a
co-founder and then the group sessions
that you'll do during start-up school
you'll be matched up with other single
founders they're meeting so you'll get
to meet talk and again we don't expect
that you're going to solidify a team
during start-up school but you at least
will start introductions and start
building that relationship which is
needed and figure out if you're gonna be
a good fit or not and we're really
really excited about that because we
think that's like one of the best things
we can do to help all these single
founders hmm and the last one is for all
these international people last year we
did the tapings weekly at our office and
we invited people to come and attend the
live tapings people are flying from all
over the world it was incredibly popular
but we felt really guilty because it was
like that's always money and time we
think for people to come for a one hour
session we're partners we are humbled
that people find think that that's worth
it and valuable yeah part of what we're
gonna do is we looked at the data for
what are the top 18 cities that people
attended or participate in start school
and we're going to go out there so we're
gonna record some lectures and we're
gonna host startup school meetups
partners are going to be in attendance
you can ask and meet with them um one
one and it's gonna be at 18 different
cities and it's gonna be I think super
exciting that these people are well one
kind of get to interact with us and we
get to interact with them which i think
is always energizing for us but the
second thing is like startup school
creates structure and community
and I think when you're meeting other
people who are going through the same
thing from the very first start of
school when it was just like a mini
conference everyone was always excited
about the energy of being in a room with
other people right who are having a
shared experience or shared ambition and
so I want to give that opportunity as
many people as possible not just the
ones who can make it to San Francisco
well in addition to that the online
community allows you to meet people near
you as well so like when you're finding
a co-founder for instance yes definitely
actually we have a fairly sophisticated
matching program for the group session
so you're matched with people based on
your time zone
your level of progress you're sort of
preferences that you put into the
software etc so Kyle Corbett he's the
person from the software team working on
start school software did an awesome job
basically looking through the data doing
a regression test and just proving that
we're gonna have a really good like
group session that other thing that
we're doing is um we we initially had it
for last year it was like you got into a
group with like 20 other startups and
you followed them all the way through
hmm
unfortunately a lot of people just drop
off over time and so those aren't people
you can count on what we've changed
instead is that you're always going to
be matched up with people who are
actively participating in surp school
and that's just determining your group
is gonna change a little bit your group
is gonna change every week actually
you'll meet more people get more people
to build into your network get more
advice but also like you're always gonna
match up with people who are serious
about this yeah which i think is also
going to improve the quality of the
program for ya yeah I hope so
and just to clarify for people listening
and watching we always put all this
content on YouTube it's not paywall
that's not behind anything absolutely
yeah
so we believe and the thing is like I
actually think the lectures are the
least important part a start school like
it's a one thing that like it brings a
lot of tension it help builds up the
brand but those lectures are a way for
people to understand and like get help
you know if they can't commit to a
10-week program but if you have the
ambition and passion and a desire the
10-week structure in terms of how we set
up group discussions the assignments the
way we hold you accountable why by
putting in like we
into our software all that is actually
the most powerful thing that can help
your startup and so again we're happy to
give away all the lectures for free it's
something that we've always done yeah
for YC and so this other part is the
part that we're trying to figure out how
to scale and the lectures are going to
be a little bit shorter this year now
they're about 20 minutes we're we're
kind of taking a cue from what's popular
from this YouTube generation yes and so
I think you can watch like people just
drop off on the hour-long sort of
lectures some people who are serious
they kind of really love it what we want
to make sure is that like you're gonna
spend 20 minutes and it's going to be
the highest quality 20 minutes that
you're gonna get
we're also I've given instructions to
all the people doing lectures that we're
focused more on practical tactical
information and then try to back up
stuff with as much case studies as
possible so therefore it would always
just feel like I'm winding on watching a
lecture and then I'm you're not gonna
feel like I don't know how to apply this
- totally yeah and so I think that'll be
a really nice difference because some
lectures I felt like for companies who
were really early they're just like I'm
so far away from even thinking about
this stuff yeah and so like to me I was
like okay great
we have room to like make a lot of great
content to help people with first
principles right it's inspiring but not
always relevant yes like those are the
ones you go back to you once you like
you have things yeah going wrong and I
think we have enough of that
inspirational content and there's
probably enough of it being created by
lots of other people yeah everyone else
yeah absolutely our answer just to be
clear signups Rovin right now when are
they open until they're open until July
22nd so pretty much right up until it
starts on that days when I release a
video like on orientation and then the
first lecture is recorded on the 25th
and then we release that live to the
public of the next day on Thursday so
down the 26th yeah right cool so let's
get do some relevant and important
advice okay we have a bunch of office
hours questions for you great many of
them I think for whatever reason maybe
it's the mood the startup school
announcement are about the early days so
we can I start up both of your startup
and just startups in general are getting
a product
so let's start with the this very simple
question in the early days of Wu fo how
did you give a great customer experience
like the basic beginning days so it's
actually relatively easy to provide a
good customer experience like I think
the default is people expect to not get
a response that it's going to be a
really slow response and the response
that I'm going to get is not relevant
mm-hmm so those are the three ways that
you can really sort of fix snoring is
make sure you respond to every single
person that has a question or a problem
issue second we responded on average
seven to twelve minutes and then the
third one is the person that's
responding your question is most likely
probably was going to be someone that
worked on the software it was an
engineer yeah and so in the early days
of woofy it was like the founders we
were answering all customer support for
the first two years and we just got
really disciplined and diligent we said
like this was going to be a number one
priority for us that if people are
taking a chance on us that we they
deserve the respect of like getting a
good response and and and we want to get
that feedback and so that made a huge
difference one is that the people
building the product like got all this
awesome feedback on like how to improve
it you also have the right sort of
feedback loop where it's just like ah
I'm tired of getting this question yeah
exactly I have to do something about it
and the result also is that um we
started doing a lot of stuff to help
people help themselves and so I would
say boo from the early days had some of
the best documentation screencast
tutorials help tips and then we also got
very diligent about like and passionate
about billing really simple intuitive
interfaces and that meant actually it
was really hard to add features to gufu
it was really hard to like add a button
or piece of copy etc cuz we just knew
that like oh that results in extra
customer support yeah or complexity and
so how can we do this with smart
defaults or ways that we do this so that
like we do it with as few different
controls or manipulations as possible
and the result is a software that just
kind of like mostly just works right out
of the gate for you hmm
kinda is doing what you want
by default if possible and that anything
that we felt like was not worth that
trade-off we would say like hey you have
to go somewhere else for that kind of
complexity because eventually people
would graduate and we would know where
we are in terms of like the life cycles
like people's form dates like at some
point you need to get a developer and
build your own app like you need if you
need something really complicated yeah
and I I like that part about your talk
recently when you were describing how
Photoshop was putting the stroke in red
and that was prompting users to learn
the settings and you did something
similar in mucho yeah so in that case I
do this talk to the batch about
affordances and so I talked about like
basically there's an affordance of
something really ugly especially in a
design app or a Photography app like
Adobe Photoshop and so when you put a
border on something the default was like
this three pixel dark red line and the
affordance of that is like designers
want to change it they'll do whatever it
takes to change that default and what it
does is it naturally gets them to learn
how to use the settings and find the
properties etc and they don't even know
they're doing it like they're being kind
of annoyed about this one thing but
they're actually learning all the skills
and all the things that will help them
change all the other settings in
Photoshop which i think is really
brilliant intuitive thing and so for us
and we've we tried to do that in a lot
of other places and a lot of that had to
do with like just helping discover
certain functions or features that would
be hidden behind tabs that were
unnatural to sort of find or to think
about and what we would do is we would
call things we would call like the the
default form untitled form know would
want to like have their form called that
so they default like naturally wanted to
click on that and as a result it
revealed all these extra settings that
were kind of like candies exact result
and they don't even realize that they
were learning something so to me I
always like that interface that like
teaches people without them realizing
they're being taught I don't think
there's many people who like signed up
for a new piece of software and they get
tossed into a walkthrough to tour and
they're like oh I'm so excited I'm all
about the wizard I don't know what
you're talking about the people who are
the best at this are video games yeah
did you a phenomenal job and the people
were worse at this is like b2b
underpriced software like I think they
don't realize like how important it is
to get that
were telling and that natural feeling
right mm-hmm they just think like oh I
just sees someone else has this force
walk through we should just do this as
well not realizing it's like the mindset
of your user is like panic trying to
evaluate it this like something's gonna
solve my media problem and so like it's
not gonna put up with any weird forced
[ __ ] yeah walk through your maze
yeah or that's part of your business
model offering expensive trainings yeah
so in their very early days of wufu that
there's a question from Sunil Tesh they
asked how is we foo 10x better than the
market when you just got started one of
those response time on a customer
support
what were the other ways so I wouldn't
call that a 10x improvement like that's
probably it's like oh that's a good
improvement but I don't know if anyone
just like oh I want to swish for great
customer that's great customer support
is actually a good one for improving
retention and it's something I also tell
people about in terms of like that's a
great like user experience and most user
experience features like a lot of people
like to be forward on them especially
designers it's like it's really
beautiful it's really easy to use
intuitive and the problem is those words
other words that like no other
competitor or no other company will ever
say the opposite of and therefore when
you use it it means nothing
yeah so they only help with the
pretension so as far as conversion is
good its concern when we built we foo it
was in like 2006 and that is the error
where like Gmail just kind of came out
and so this edge of the world where a
jack was brand new and then the idea of
building a modern web app that felt kind
of like a desktop came into being and so
all the other form builders at the time
was literally it was like a page refresh
for every change you want to make and so
it made that process of creating a form
really really difficult so one thing is
like we changed the level response
matsuda you could build form really
quickly the other thing we did on top of
that was build an interface that was
like simple drag-and-drop like it was it
was WYSIWYG like so other people's like
a forum board builder is a really
interesting user interface challenge
because it's an interface that builds
interfaces so there's all this weird
kind of complexity so you have to kind
of show what is the difference between
like my interface the tool
that's helping you build and the
interface I'm trying to actually create
mhm and so a lot of the aesthetic
weirdness of WWOOF who had to do with
like this all does crazy colorful stuff
this is we fool and and there's stuff
that you're building that's probably
this drab gray and white form like this
it was really easy to distinguish
between the two and so being able to
drag-and-drop and be like hey what you
know you want as a non-technical person
is like I need to collect the name email
address a bunch of questions etc so you
know what you're looking for you you've
seen other people do it and you want to
copy what you've seen a lot of other
apps at the time had this different
kinds of approaches one of them were
just like hey we're database application
builder and so they would start with
being like what's this the structured
data that you need telling me how to all
this stuff and so what end up having is
like you had to know too much about
development to build the forms instead
of being like hey I just need to copy
what I want and can you just magically
make it work and so that magic was the
big thing that was changed and when we
started with you we were able to prove
that it was going to field that fast mhm
by releasing actually an interface demo
so the very first thing that we launched
so I think we got into YC for winter
2006 we rubbed the first lines of code
in January of that year we launched an
interface demo in early February meaning
a video screen work no no no it was like
an interactive okay so what you all you
could do was like drag and drop the
fields that you want and then pretend
like you're gonna hit save like you look
like you're changing all the settings
for it and then you hit save and what it
came up a prompted was just like hey
you've just completed the interface that
move oh if you're interested in like
using you know using this builder for
other forms in the future
sign up okay we got over a hundred
thousand people who went through that
demo and gave us emails in that
interface prototype basically it showed
people kind of like drop boxes like
video demo is like oh this is what it
should feel like this is what it should
look like and so by making it so it was
like no signups to the feel what the
change was gonna be like for us that
like help people be like oh I can
imagine myself using this or I can
imagine myself giving this as someone
else and that they could use it yes and
not have me build this really tedious
thing which is a form where were you
distributing that at the time we had
started a blog so when we first
got started in entrepreneurship we
realize we do nothing yes sir and we had
attended a talk at South by Southwest by
Jason free it's called doing big things
with small teams and they mentioned that
37signals that they were blogging for
years before they finally released
Basecamp their first product and so they
had an audience of huge you know
hundreds of thousands of people who
followed them before they launch and so
when they got started they were not
starting from zero mm-hmm and they their
piece of advice they had was like build
an audience first and we're like we
don't have an audience and we don't have
a product so let's you know start doing
that yeah so that night we registered a
domain called particle tree comm and
then we just started writing about stuff
that we didn't know anything about like
literally we would research stuff about
entrepreneurship about design and about
business like the three things were like
this is all going to need to know its
right to start a startup like a
technical startup and so we would
research the stuff and we'd write these
beautiful essays it was something like
part of my expertise I knew like I
studied modern American literature
I was energy for my newspaper and I was
like I'd know publishing I know how we
can write this stuff so that it's clear
for people yes
and so that's how I start and we build
that readership to a hundred thousand
subscribers this was like the heyday of
like delicious and Slashdot and so like
good content got spread around pretty
easily and it's actually Paul Graham had
recognized us from our blog hmm and
that's why I think we got it that was
like our proof that we got stuff done
right you can at least make something
someone wants maybe it's an essay so
we've been riding on that blog for
multiple years about two years and so
when we launched this prototype we
launched it on the blog hey we've you
know we've taken all these skills and
we're starting to build a company we're
building this product come check it out
so we had all these readers who were
developers and other entrepreneurs who
actually are ideal customers coming in
to try a thing and number one they're
not starting it was not like they were
coming in and be like I'm evaluating and
I don't know if I trust this company or
whatever they're like these guys have
been writing and been generous for
multiple years I already trust them I'm
excited about using the stick thing that
they've been so generous about all right
so that changed the relationship but
also allowed us to like out of the gate
yes be able to start ahead of the curve
that other people like wait until they
finally build a product right or at that
time like launch in TechCrunch or
something right so you you create that
early pop did you guys have any
interesting referral mechanisms or Regis
word-of-mouth um so when we finally
launched of wufu has by its very nature
could spread itself so what we had his
arm
we had a freemium product and on the
free plan on the confirmation page it
would say it was powered by Wufoo so we
just had like naturally like as people
created forums and shared it with other
people on our behalf they would see oh
great the second thing is we built this
innovation is allow forms to be ended
embedded on other people's websites so
that was like a new thing like people
would embed weird chat widgets and other
images and galleries and stuff but
embedding a forum was unique hmm and so
we had signed it so that Weaver forms
could be embedded so you could you know
you don't redirect them you put them on
your own website what it meant was like
a whoohoo form that says powered by
Wufoo was put on all these different web
sites as well okay and would link also
back to us okay so upon completion it
does it a jump reload in the page and
then you see the logo well you would see
on the confirmation page but also on the
free plan if you embed it you would see
that this form was created okay with
both of those things would mean that
like our users were spreading the gospel
on our behalf and not sort of helped
secondly confirmation emails also had
etcetera so there's all these like nice
mechanisms yeah that allowed that to
sort of work we had the reputation from
the blog and then we had really great
word-of-mouth as a result like the
product just worked really well people
like we're satisfied with customer sort
to help them deal with whatever sort of
will weird features and I think it was
the design of it because it was so
strange like it's a very casual app for
something that's meant for like a lot of
business and like yeah mister logics
stuff sure it's like red and yellows
like McDonald's colors the mascots are
weird t-rex has all this weird kind of
like things that if you look at
MailChimp software that you will
recognize that is cute and wet et cetera
it was a personality of an app that
you're like oh I would like to be
friends with whoever made it
but what it did was and made people
smile when they use it and was easy to
remember to recommend it to other
people's like hey here's an app that I
actually don't doesn't make me want to
kill myself remind me that I'm working
in a cubicle right unlike all the other
apps it is a five which was all grey and
blue very boring and kind of dull yeah
those little things that show that
there's actually a human behind the
screen goes so far especially in the
early days uh definitely I think
definitely for sticking out yeah because
if someone's evaluating a bunch of
different tools then it's like Oh what
are you gonna do to stick out and so if
everyone's comparing you against a
checklist of stuff man there's gonna be
like it's gonna be hard to be like if
they're only maximizing this stuff and
so in the early days Weaver didn't have
a checklist of all the things that have
so we had to rely on one this extreme
ease of use and then also this
friendliness mm-hmm like it's like oh
I'm here and then while there's a lack
of jargon and the help kind of talks to
me a way that's very human rather than
in a way that like it's like a robot
talking to a developer etc and so that
humanizing element made it be like oh I
can trust this app to be given to my
non-technical people yeah and the
roofies support is so good that they're
not gonna bother me
we've you got easily recommended by
technical people all the time so to back
up and given I I know like some of the
startup school content coming out let's
talk about even just coming up with the
idea for woof ooh I know it's a big
thing for people getting into startup
school some people like sort of have an
idea where did the idea come from and
then how did it evolve during YC so
before I get started I just want to make
it clear if you don't have an idea or a
bunch of ideas but you don't know what
to pick
startup school is gonna be great for you
we've actually got lectures dedicated to
that topic and so I think that's gonna
be helpful and then if you're working on
an idea and you're like I don't know if
it's really working and it's really
pivot we've got a lecture for you as
well for us we actually pit
like back in the day you could pitch
multiple ideas it wasn't like a separate
question for what other ideas you had
you could put multiple in the same
application yeah something like that
word like or you can submit multiple and
so when we got accepted for an interview
we had we had two ideas we'd submit it
and we had to actually ask the head of
time we're like oh we had submitted two
ideas which one should we prepare and
they had responded very quickly and they
were like just prepare for both of them
so we're like okay cool thanks so we do
all this work and we come into the room
yeah and the first idea they meet they
me there goes no no no if we're not
interested at all like they knew
immediately one we like just described
it like no we don't want to you what was
it it was an affiliate link marketplace
base yeah okay not very interesting like
about you know there there are big
businesses doing that but like I'm glad
we didn't go down that road I don't
think that would have been unsatisfying
and then this other one was not actually
woohoo the way we described it we called
it a new type of content manager with
something we called reversible forms so
the idea was that like oh you know the
form that you fill it on the backend of
WordPress that's a form and then the
comments form is also formed so what if
you made it so that forms could be like
private or public
we called it reversible we made all this
new jargon that's why we decided to
describe horrible way to subscribe right
the product and peachy kind of looked at
us of meeting the image just like kinda
was like oh wait you're talking him out
and there's like I think you're building
a form builder right and the we of
course I had already like researched a
little bit of the market we're like we
don't want to build a form brother we've
seen the other products in the space
they're boring they look terrible
that's not space you want to be content
managers at that time where the hot
thing was like moveable type and
WordPress they were like blowing up we
thought like they're doing interesting
stuff it in the product space we want to
be in there and then what we didn't
recognize until a little bit after that
interview was like oh that's the whole
point like that's the opportunity all
these people are bad in this space and
obviously they're being supported you
know there's enough people doing it but
like no one has really conquered it yep
and so for us like that pivot happened
in the middle of the interview and we
were we had
in a single line we didn't even explain
the idea very well etc and so it's
actually one of the like big passions
about why I'm doing startup school is
like I worry that people think that
companies like mine back in the day
cannot get into YC and even though we
constantly try to say is like we do take
single founders we do take people
without an idea we mostly focus on the
team a lot of people just like here what
happens at demo day and they hear these
teams with crazy traction they think
like if I don't have that how can I
possibly get it and the answer is like
you don't need that and would start at
school I hopefully will make people feel
more comfortable that's like oh there's
a program that explicitly says you can
come here to get help with that and then
actually we're able to use that
information that relationship with those
founders during start-up school to
actually say like hey yeah we want to
take you in actually most of the start
school graduates that we took many of
them were like pre traction and who many
of them were had very very little
traction that we took and some of them
were pivoted after they got accepted
into the batch actually well that's what
I wanted to talk about so like not to
name names but we're in the middle of
the batch our you know the first third
of the batch right now people are summer
batch for the summer batch yeah people
are restarting they're completely
pivoting trying again like all the
polish that people project onto YC
companies that get in that are in the
batch it's not always true
sometimes the pivot happens a week
before demo day yeah and then they still
will be able to race it's a [ __ ] because
number one most investors invest in
teams and number two if you do the
storytelling and if the idea is sound
enough it makes sense those two combined
that a great team and an idea that is
well thought out and told really well to
people that's enough to get people
excited because like what I am as an
investor is trying to figure out is like
can I imagine a world where this team
with this idea I'm going to succeed
that's actually the baseline for like
seed investment it is not that like I
have to have a crazy amount of proof
that this is gonna be 10 billion dollars
or I'm not interested in all mm-hmm that
is not why C's model like we would like
that we would like teams to be but we
are humble and
honorable enough and part of the shotgun
model as based on the fact that is like
we actually can't accurately predict
who's going to be a ten billion dollar
company right so we invest in two
hundred companies in a batch several
hundred year yeah so you talking about
woohoo has an unsexy idea do you have a
mental model for finding unsexy mark
markets or products that people can use
a mental model um I don't think about it
like that like here's the thing I if you
are a really great product technical
team yeah you're entering an unsexy
space that's good because you're
entering a space with like less
competitors but those who are like great
product teams but entering in like
consumer spaces it's like my god that is
a crazy mad max arena yeah where a lot
of good people are vying for that stuff
and it gets really really difficult and
so to me entering a tedious boring space
is about mindset about like what's your
mission and the best advice I've got I'd
heard about this it actually comes from
Ben chestnut he's the founder of
MailChimp and he says it's like I don't
like people who are obsessed with like
only doing what they love that's like a
recipe for being unhappy like you're
like if I don't love it I'm not going to
do it because like number one like
that's not practical oftentimes in life
and also you kind of sound like a brat
right it's like oh so you won't do
anything you won't do the hard stuff you
won't do anything it's difficult etc he
actually says the skill you most want is
like figuring out how to love whatever
it is that you do and so that is is like
it doesn't matter if I'm building a form
builder I'm making a weird widget or I'm
writing a piece of like boring email
copy or marketing or doing whatever to
start like I have figured out a way to
like make it my own and I will do the
best version of it hmm a lot of roof
whose personality has come out it was
like oh I have to make this like
confirmation billing receipt all right I
can do this the really boring tedious
way where I will hate it all the way
through or I can figure I was like oh
where can I put some sparkle and magic
in here so therefore is like I'm proud
of it mm-hmm and
we're Fuu you easily gonna be like oh no
one wants to bake form building their
life's work but to me I was like oh this
is a body of work that I am so proud of
because like everything in it was
something we're like oh I put some
attention to detail and at a fundamental
level it just worked right yeah geez
proms are also like usually huge markets
there so like if you want to make money
and you can like bring yourself to do
that like that's like a great motivation
yeah and I think often I mean
you've read men search for meaning right
like oh yeah that's great
I mean it's terribly sad but it's great
and this idea is core to it but also the
fact that you know like people love
getting good at games
full-stop and so getting making the best
form builder that's huge and then also I
think it's helpful for people to just
imagine what it is like to win whatever
game they want to play and just play it
out in their head and then you can just
keep pushing it's actually a big part of
the philosophy and religion and like
that deals with like mindfulness hmm you
know like sweeping the temple it is like
you can do it in a way that is like not
mindful not present or you can do it in
a way where it's like oh I'm paying
attention I'm learning stuff about
myself in the world and actually being
there and so yeah I don't know like I
think founders who figure out how to be
happy working on what sounds like not
sexy those people usually have the right
mindset in their head about work about
how they think about stuff and so like I
get excited about it yeah let's just I
mean just having a customer driven
mindset makes a huge difference all
right so shifting a little bit to
slightly later stage civil Raj Ganesh s
how do you know if you've achieved
product market fit
so for whoa foo what was the point I
don't think you did you ever get there I
don't think there's any given point
okay so I'll tell you this roof is such
a different company than most because we
only raised 118 thousand dollars for the
whole life of the company so 80 so back
in 2006 place he was only giving $18,000
and then we only raise from two angels
$50,000 each and that was that and ruku
was a company that only had ten
employees when we got acquired not five
and a half years later and we had done
that on purpose and we had profit
sharing so when we gave equity to the
employ like we didn't hire anybody for
the first two years by choice it was
three of you and it was just three of us
yeah
and then when we gave equity employees
were like we're not gonna give stock
options we're shouldn't give you equity
but the result of that is that it's
gonna be really hard to get that equity
you have to really sort of earn it
because by that time we had to risk a
lot of like the growth mechanics of we
feel like the revenues were just
basically almost doubling every year and
so with the profit sharing my salary was
actually doubling every year we the
thing is we couldn't think of any place
to put the money that would help it grow
faster or we'll make it better that was
like literally how efficient we were and
we had talked to so many other companies
and actually after we got acquired by
SurveyMonkey we actually were really
relieved because we looked at all the
other stuff that they tried and we're
just like yeah the more there's like
nothing out like it's [ __ ] our business
was the kind it's like the market is so
huge and it's just nice and steady hmm
and so I believe there's a type of
billion-dollar company where it's like
if you can figure out how to do this
craft and do this work for ten years no
no it's it's inevitable and so
increasing burn like crazy and spending
a bunch of pay marketing you could have
spend a ton of money on that so Facebook
was really brand new at a time Twitter
just got it invented so there wasn't to
me Google Google right but no one's
searching form builder we did we were
successful at getting a lot of SEO
traffic yeah the way we did that was we
built a form gallery and so every
different type of form you could build
there was like a dedicated landing page
it's like hey you can have a contact
form in like one second and one click so
that was really successful for us for
people with searching that way there's
no need to buy an ad for that and it was
one of the things that was a trade off
like what do we want from the culture of
our company I got to choose based on our
growth rate and the mechanic
at the company and we had interviewed
like again our roots was with this blog
to learn about all this stuff
so we researched things like what was
the literature saying about best
practices for management hiring etc and
so a lot of and then we interviewed tons
of other like entrepreneurs and asking
them just like at various different
stages of the company and especially in
the early days of like YC talking to
tons of other founders and we would find
out was like what made people happy want
me people not happy and hiring like
crazy was consistently everyone was like
when my company got to a certain stage
and I had this many people around me
that I didn't even know who they were
I hated it and so for us was like do
that yes let's not make it so that this
management thing and bringing on people
that we're not passionate and care about
not gonna be a part of it and so like
that became a core mission is it make us
efficient and the profit sharing helped
reinforce that and then those values got
help everyone be on board for like why
everyone should do customer support in
the company who's like hey know if we
have to bring on more people to do this
stuff like that eats away at our own
success eats away at the culture that we
don't want to change too much etc so all
of it was reinforcing well so yeah I was
gonna say just trying to get back to the
question yeah when do you know if you've
achieved product my office so as a
result I feel like there's never really
been a clear definition for it but the
the ones that talk about like breakaway
startup success they say product market
fit is one where it's like you feel out
of control like you're no longer driving
the boat I don't feel like we were ever
at that point but I would not say that
we were not at product market fit so
that's like the weird thing like we were
we were not a company that was gonna
have an inflection point that was going
to grow to some right an exponential
rate well we were a company that was in
charge of our own destiny and we were
not trying to figure out where the new
customers gonna come from or who's gonna
beat us etcetera and so it was a very
different kind of life but it's like I
felt like we had product market fit but
it was controlled yeah
so to me it's like it's just different
like there's an argument that you make
is the path that we have and that I have
to talk to companies about this like you
might have a growth pattern that's not
going to justify venture capital and we
were really lucky to recognize that and
we did not give up extra equity to get
money to try to see if like are there
other avenues of birth or females that
would make that happen and the result is
all the founders had so much equity in
the company and that our employees who
got equity actually had equity in the
company not just like options and shares
or just a tiny fraction and so when the
exit happened our exit like equivalent
for us is something that would been
three times larger for some other
company in terms of returns back to the
founders etc so that's like a whole
different thing that you can anybody and
I think a lot of people don't talk about
well I mean that's like very much
related to what I was saying before as I
could think about this game that you're
about to enter into and what does it
actually look like to win that game and
I think for many many many years I think
we lose returns we're still like one of
the top returns back for YC as a result
yeah a dollar for Daria yes totally
exactly and so that's something to keep
in mind it is like a company like mine
is considered a big win for YC also but
it requires discipline of the founders
yeah and also recognizes a different
Channel that being said my type of
company is so rare actually this is not
the comment it's not like it's a choice
it's actually not many companies have
the luxury of being able to grow that I
felt like we were really lucky to have
that path and they recognize it and not
create a bunch of extra burn and give up
extra equity many people who might have
that be a path they're like oh I gave up
all this I clean it out all this you
know and and then I increase my burn
that like I don't have a chance to go
back definitely do this other path
definitely know if that's that's another
angle of it but most companies who are
successful actually are once that oh you
figured out there's a rocket ship
they're the ones you mostly hear about
but I would say like those are actually
more common for YC than the ones who are
like steady growth and eventually bb-big
yeah so would your advice then be just
run the experiments incredibly cheaply I
figure out
you should always be frugal I think any
partner YC will say you should always be
frugal that's number one number two
understand fully number one
why you're giving up the equity and why
you're increasing the burn those are two
big sacrifices and so you should have a
very strong level of confidence that
giving up those two things are actually
going to result in growth I think a lot
of people will give them up prematurely
mm-hmm thinking it will result in growth
and so when that happens it's usually a
tragedy almost always a tragedy that
happens and so this was why I'd like our
biggest advice that's kind of ignored is
treat every fund raised as if it's your
last people just think that's the point
of this game unfortunately the only
product market fit I had a very
different kind it's an extremely rare
kind that you normally don't hear about
the kind that you mostly about those
ones where it's like oh my god we have
something that's so good for the market
is that we we can barely hold on and we
have to hire like crazy etc and so you
if you have to ask the question you
definitely don't have it that's number
one and number two don't give up
everything to try to achieve it like
again it's one of those things where
like you know kind of right away yeah
whether it's gonna work well they they
had a little addition to this question
okay which was on the other hand how do
you know if your product just isn't even
noticed yet and so I mean I think you
could lump this into the category of
like do you have a hundred people that
love it but what would you say to that
so there's two things and actually you
should refer to Don Caldwell's content
so he did a video on the YouTube about I
think pivoting a little bit and then
also he actually did like a tweet storm
about a bunch of ideas on how companies
get locked into too much like being
really diligent I actually think it's
extremely difficult to know when to give
up because there's no shortage of
stories of founders who like they just
kept at it and then finally something
clicked right and there's a
there's others or there's plenty of
stories where it's like we finally gave
up and changed and then that thing went
right it was like yes so to me I
actually feel like there's no good
answer yeah quite honestly it's like
this is where you need a little bit of
luck and the question is like you kinda
are actually asking your own self is
like what are you gonna be happy with
yeah right so the if you are just like
man I just want a company that like I'm
proud of etcetera then there's a certain
level growth that you people you can
want if your goal is like I want a
company that is going to be a [ __ ]
rocket ship then yeah you need to
basically be like alright is it a rocket
ship right a rocket ship is a rocket
ship and then there's a certain point we
you want to say it's like well it's not
a rocket ship and that point is usually
before you run out of money and I would
I would recommend is that you want like
when you start getting down to nine
months yeah of runway you should start
seriously asking yourself how about like
what would have to change definitively
for me to know that this is a rocket
ship yeah
what would have to figure out and then
you'd like time box it cuz like once you
run out of money it's game over and then
the lower the money gets the lower the
leverage that you have to ask up from
somewhere else they bought help buy more
time well and you're just shrinking the
amount of time you have to run
experiments so you can't you're not
finding anything out you're not learning
they asked one more question that I
think is also quite common for
early-stage founders people doing
startup school how do you even get the
size of a market oh how do you gauge the
size of the market that's a little bit
of research I feel like in whatever
space that you're in you're gonna have a
rough understanding of it like basic
demographics there's tons of research
studies on all these different
industries usually companies themselves
especially big ones are touting how big
the market or what the opportunity is so
you
I feel like that's easy to find I think
more importantly what you're trying to
figure out is like and I talked about
this in an early YouTube video it's like
understanding like does my model even
make sense is it person is it even plaus
a bowl that I can be become a billion
dollar company and what I talked about
is you're just trying to figure out like
Oh based on how much you charge or the
average amount of revenue you're gonna
get from someone how many customers do
you have to have to get to one hundred
million dollars in revenue and I do this
with all my companies I actually had two
that pivoted this batch after we read
through that exercise they were like oh
my company's not a really bad model it's
not gonna work like I either because
it's either I need to increase how much
I'm charging or I need a really great
acquisition strategy to get at those
numbers
mhm and then once you have the number
the question is this a market even
support that and as an investor I'm
usually thinking is like okay if they
need to capture more than ten percent of
the market just to get to that hundred
million dollar revenue that's probably
not possible but yeah I've seen numbers
where it's like oh we need to get like a
hundred thousand customers but then like
the number of customers in the market is
like 150 thousand only and therefore
it's like oh that's gonna not be
plausible I mean you see stuff all the
time it's like well if we get everyone
in America we're gonna be a total hit so
you shouldn't do that I actually think
you always want to do this bottom-up
calculation and then for consumer apps
it's there's probably always going to be
a lot of people the bigger part of that
equation that you're focused on is like
I don't get at these like two three
hundred thousand people that's needed to
make this consumer startup worth a
billion dollars
yeah and so if you if your answer is I'm
gonna pay for every single one of them
man you now have to give up so much
equity in your company to do that so the
ones that we get excited about once we
figured out like I figured out a trick
for people to recommend me to do this
for free or like have other people act
as my sales I don't my behalf mmm-hmm so
for this last section yeah let's go into
some hardcore startup school advice so a
lot of people are gonna churn fewer
people than the average Mook way fewer
but people will turn what kind of
mentality should someone adopt to ensure
like at least completion but hopefully
success in startup school so for us so
at the end of the program but we have
people do is apply to YC YC and then
when you apply you're also applying to
you get this $15,000 equity free grant
so the most promising startups
startup school we give out those grants
simultaneously we look at those
applications also consider them for the
the YC core program is yeah so it's like
a two-for-one in that application the
minimum requirements for applying for
that is you have to complete eight out
of ten weekly updates so basically every
week we send out a thing that we say
like hey how many users have you talked
to and what have you learned or like how
much revenue like what is your main KPI
like whether it's engagement or revenue
like how much have you done and again it
it's not that it has to go up every
single time but you have to at least
submit the updates mhm if you don't
submit the updates you don't get
considered for group office hours
because you're not active etc so that's
like that's the minimum is like you
spend ten minutes a week right
riding enough day about what you're
doing on your startup and what progress
that you've made so that's like you know
that basic requirement seek requirement
yeah and I would like to think that like
if you're thinking about your startup
and for most people that I know who
think about their serve it's like
non-stop this should be an easy thing to
do the reason people don't do that is
because like the truth really [ __ ]
sucks
yep um and so it's a large thing that we
actually do with our own YC companies is
I have to get them to be like you as an
entrepreneur I've been born with like
some kind of broken gene that makes you
more optimistic than other people but
what that means is you're gonna lie to
yourself I'm here to fix that gene like
I'm a crisper and so I hope you look at
the honest truth about where you really
are at in your startup and so that
update is like there to help you see
that when you're finally honest about
like oh you know what my KPI is revenue
and since I'm pre-launch it's zero and
then the next week at zero again yeah I
gotta show you something I gotta change
something or I need to speed up etc and
sort of like what you want is to look at
startup school and be like for this ten
weeks hmm I'm gonna go through these
exercises I'm gonna ask these hard
questions of myself and my co-founder
and this is why it's art schools I think
is also great for companies who are
already working on a start-up because it
goes back to these first principles and
then be honest about those answers
that's number one number two
participate in the group sessions so
like every week we're gonna match you up
with six to eight other people on
Thursday evenings is kind of what we
figured out was the ideal time for
everyone across all time zones and
you're gonna talk about your startup and
actually those group sessions are very
simple you actually are practicing
talking about what you do it's what we
mostly do in YC is fixing your narrative
and storytelling because people come in
and they're so bad at talking about what
they're doing and because it's not clear
people can't understand if they can't
understand it can't get excited if they
can't excited you can't grow and you
can't recruit and you can't get people
to invest etc so fixing that story is
the most important part and so we're
giving you an opportunity to do that
with lots of people and actually we have
software that when you're in the video
sessions and you're saying like hi my
company is this this is my one-liner
people will be able to now say to you is
like I understand what you're building
I'm excited about the problem you're
working on and then are you the kind of
team that like I would want to work for
so getting understanding it's like how
do you project and present yourself
because well because those three things
are a lot of what we're trying to
evaluate a lot of people I feel like I
talked to you about their company it's
low energy they're not passionate and
those aren't people that attract other
people because anyone that's going to
build a billion-dollar company they need
to be able to attract other people to
this and so I think startup schools also
successful the people were committed to
that process of like I'm going to try to
get real feedback and I'm gonna practice
talking about my company I'm gonna fix
my narrative and get it to the end where
people like hear what I'm talking about
they immediately get excited and that
its own and it's so exciting and I do
such a good job that people are
attracted to me last question a high
percentage of these people are solo
founders say they are looking for a
co-founder what would be your advice
given it's a relatively short period of
time on vetting co-founders
okay getting a co-founder is like
getting married to someone yeah lovely
like even way more intense and and then
you and you and you don't have usually
sex to relieve the tension or fix a
bunch of things are smooth things over
or a different job you have usually a
chemical that's helping fix a lot of
things that are problems and so I
actually think it's like you're you
should treat it very similar to like
what would you get married like you
don't immediately like talk to someone
figure out a bunch of characteristics
and on the first date go like let's get
married yes so what you're actually
doing when you value co-founders is
you're dating and the dating should be
small number one is like do you
understand each other do you have
complementary skills right like do you
like just talking with them do you think
that you would like to spend more time
with them so that's like the first
question cuz you had to spend a whole
lot of time so that's that's like the
big thing is like oh I would just
practice that like oh I like discussing
talking et cetera the second stage would
be is like oh okay
do i is there some kind of small thing
that we can do for each other
mm-hmm I always start with small favors
it's like oh I'll research this question
and I'll get back to you or like oh I'll
look at that or I'll send you some
recommendations etc like how are they
reliable in terms of exchanging small
stuff and then you move on to it's like
hey maybe we will try building something
or maybe we'll try doing something etc
and then you move on to like alright
let's have a conversation about like hey
do you want to work more long-term do we
want to like commit more resources to
that like I think you can time box
everything and work your way up
and so the dating is super important I
think founders single founders are
unsuccessful when they are kind of
desperate about it yep that's the same
problem in normal dating yes actually
the second thing is it can't be all take
it's like oh I have a great idea and I'm
looking for a technical co-founder to do
all the work
you have to be good at selling yourself
unlike what your contribution and what
you're gonna be able to do ceteris and
if it's if your concrete is
non-technical then like you know there's
good examples of this Alexis Ohanian is
my favorite example of a non-technical
founder he did everything else right
he's like I'm gonna smooth this over for
you
and that's something that can be really
appealing that's someone who just like
is like I know I'm gonna have to build
this what about what given that you
compared to dating dating multiple
people in the beginning that's totally
fine startup school I'm so loud
uh yeah I think you should probably have
conversation with lots of people like
you never really know I feel like the
only reason I did my startup is because
I met my co-founders I never thought
about entrepreneurship like I was
supposed to like get my MFA and teach
art to hippies I feel like making money
was the farthest thing from my mind
yeah and I would say like college Kevin
would like really punch myself in this
in the face and call me a sellout if you
knew what I was doing now all right
awesome so startup school signups are
available where they're open at startup
school.org and registrations up until
July 22nd awesome all right thanks for
coming in man thanks Greg
you